hey guys i'm here with gina grad we are
back at Roseanne's kitchen table we
moved the table and we had a whole new
thing going on behind us I like it
better alright so I want to talk about
the interview I don't know if you guys
have heard about this do you think
they've possibly heard about this the
big Sony hack and then the threat of
some sort of 9 11 terror situation than
sony got rid they said we're not going
to show the interview then just in the
last hour now suddenly a couple theaters
apparently one in Atlanta one in Dallas
are going to show it on Christmas Day
now it's going to be released online
that's at least what it sounds like and
this could change a little bit but I am
completely fascinated by this story
completely fascinating yeah and first of
all if you haven't heard of this yeah
you are one hundred percent trapped
under something heavy and someone should
go find you there anyone that hasn't
heard of this story at this point Helen
you probably have to have heard it so
the real to me what what I think was
really fascinating about is the
dangerous part of this is that we
decided to limit our afraid of them
Express of expression as Americans or at
least Sony decided to just because of
the threat of terrorism now obviously
they had some seriously messed-up [ __ ]
in those emails like they're definitely
could have been oh they were we know
your ending they were career-ending
stuff there was stuff about you know
salaries that yeah we're paid out it
sounds like there was some racial stuff
which celebrities a spoiled brat which
one you never want to work with so
terrible stuff but to be blackmailed by
a government or by hackers or whatever
it was a really bad precedent so I'm I'm
very thankful I'm thankful in this
holiday season that we're gonna get to
see a movie actually that I wasn't even
intending on doing what because it
looked pretty low budget so i guess this
all is sort of ending nicely which I
like that it's who's to say first of all
I I don't know that anyone was super
stoked about this movie but now everyone
feels like they have to see it you're
not held to see it because what this
almost started world war three so I
gotta at least check it out for five
minutes yeah but you know I think Mel
Brooks put it best the other night I
came here what show he was on when he
said when I did the producers at least I
waited until Hitler was dead and you
know what like right he has a point I
mean you're you're poking fun at a
sitting dictator of a nation who starves
his people and feeds his
uncle to dogs yeah and you didn't expect
anything to come of this this joke right
so that's kind of interesting so as we
talked about last week with Kelly Carlin
comedy is tragedy plus time absolute in
this case it's happening right now the
horrors of what's going on North Korea
is happening right now so it does make
it a little a little different i suppose
but did you feel something really weird
for the few days that it actually
sounded like this thing wasn't going to
happen yeah to me it felt awful like as
someone that's a creator and that I try
to you know put what I think out of your
expression obviously I believe in all
that stuff and it felt kind of terrible
like we were almost doing it to
ourselves yeah I I have really really
polarizing opinions on this just
internally you know as an artist and
whatever artist um I don't know maybe
something lady go I got nothing but uh
oh but I do sweet paint by numbers
because bob ross used to have a line
anyway um I feel like yeah like we're
being stifled and this is insane and
what are we doing couch owing to this
what are we doing and then I was like
pull it back let's get out of our own
way let's get our egos out of our own
way and look at the bigger picture and
that's what I thought this is a nation
that we are thank God we're free to do
you know pretty much whatever we want
you know we could say we want without
certain on a persecution there watching
this all the time it hi big brother and
you know and whatever but also we are
poking a bear that does not care about
human life so it's all fun and games to
us because we've never known anything
else but this is very very real to other
people in other parts of the world and I
I don't know if it's good bad right or
wrong I'm just sick of everyone acting
surprised yeah it's there's a lot to it
because I was also thinking like if this
had come from something internal like
let's say it was the Tea Party I'm just
picking a group I think our internal
dialogue would have been very different
people would have been relentlessly
attacking the tea party just for any any
group I'm just trying the D word but any
group that threatened terrorism to get
some creative thing off so that's what I
was so disturbed by is that the slope
that this would have led us down so
thankfully and it sounds like America's
doing a little sign because North Korea
internet at the night and not that they
day yeah is it they said at most two or
three thousand people in the country had
access to internet so yeah two or three
thousand people can't bleh you know
candy crush with their friends yeah okay
there you go but also President Obama is
a really really big fan of both these
actors as he said in the press
conference he said I love Seth Rogen and
I love James flaco yeah so clearly he's
gonna go to bat for them either way cuz
they go my mac absolutely if you're not
exactly sure why that's funny you can
probably google it anyway what do you
guys think about this is our freedom of
expression kind of on the ropes did we
make a little come back here by getting
this book out are you even gonna go see
about it and did you care about it
before any of this happened I'll let us
know in the comments right down below